how do you motivate your business
partners we're going to answer that
question in today's episode of lunch and
earn so Risa got a question for one of
my YouTube followers love you guys
Jesse who wrote in to say hey Evan love
your videos thanks Jesse
currently I'm working with two other
guys to build a business me and the
second business partner are really
motivated and consistent but the third
person is not really consistent or
motivated could you do a video on what
could help motivate your business
partners or give tips to motivate them
Thank You Evan so what do you think I
think I don't have an answer you're
gonna want to hear I think you can't
make anyone do anything I think if
they're not passionate if they're not
motivated if they're not carrying their
weight if they're not bringing what
you're bringing to it why are you
buildings why are you building their
portion of the business they are
bringing very very little you are
bringing in your other partner bringing
a lot it seems to me that the answer is
not to motivate them you you let them go
you cut them loose you figure out a way
to lose the deadweight and maybe that
shock of being dropped will wake them up
maybe it'll fire them up maybe the
passion will be there but chances are
probably not unless if you're working on
like you know if they have a family
situation if they have a life situation
if something heavy is happening that
they're working through give them a bit
of forgiveness but for the most part if
they're not there working then why are
they a part of the business it's a curve
ball answer and I like it I like it I
got nothing else to add I'm good
mark their grants is the question did we
answer this question no what we did we
helped them okay so let's say you're not
Jesse and you need to motivate people is
there ever a time where you can do that
they're a partner they're not they're
not an employee they're not a staff
member their partner can you ever
motivate someone to work harder I think
in reality you're gonna have your people
gonna have ups and downs we're gonna
have slumps right you don't come to work
even me I don't come to work every day
super motivated right and I wake up and
like rah right he does sometimes it's
like I think I think the motivation
should be the mission what are you doing
right what are you guys here to do why
are you waking up every day who are you
trying to serve how you trying to help
and if somebody is not motivated by that
mission why are they there like go let
them do something that they are more
motivated by that's okay right people
love believe and people think believe is
stupid right
people who think believe it's
that's awesome right like self eliminate
I don't want you part of my team you'll
be happier somewhere else is better for
both of us
and the people who love believe join and
they love it and for the most part are
motivated and we're doing projects that
excite them and so I think the only
other things that I do to increase the
motivation is just letting people see
the results of their work so I'm spoiled
in my business that I get to see you
guys and get to get your emails and your
comments and how much everything is
helping you and there's a lot of people
behind the scenes who don't get to see
all of that stuff right I've got 16
people working for me five of them only
on the YouTube channel and if you're
behind the scenes you don't so you'll
get to see all the people saying hey
this really changed my life thank you so
much for these videos and so every week
I'll cut some of the best comments and
share it with everybody in team to let
them know that what they're doing is
having a big impact which is good it's
good but it's like they need that just
to get excited I feel like you have the
wrong person on your team you know I was
talking to someone who's starting a
video production business and and they
have a number of partners and I was
trying to explain to them that the
partners that they have on startup are
super important because you want that
cheap labor right like you need your
partners to help you produce the workers
you have no cash flow you have no you
have no work but as the business becomes
more and more successful those partners
are doing work that's potentially
replaceable and so yes on startup you
need partners at times you need that
partnership at times to get people who
believe in do stuff but the other thing
you got to keep in mind is as your
business grows the work that each
partner brings will be less valuable to
the business so you know you always got
to be evaluating your partnerships and
make sure that everyone's bringing
something to the table
I like it so hopefully that helps Jesse
not the question that you asked but the
question that we both wanted to answer
know this is gonna help drop the guy so
our question for you guys today is you
know they say finding a business partner
is like being us in a second marriage so
I'd like to know what's the thing you
should be looking for if you're looking
to get hooked up in a business marriage
hook that I like it leave it in the
comments below
we're gonna join in the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe I know see you soon
I want to know what the one thing that
Evan does on his videos that drive you
guys all crazy
go trolls now
you